[Musique]
ce sont eux qui ont enlevé le monolithe
dans le désert de l'utah
cette vidéo de revendications et mise en
ligne sur youtube par un certain andy
lewis un funambule et adeptes de sports
extrêmes
ce photographe assisté à la scène ans il
confirme bien que vendredi soir quatre
hommes sont arrivés ont fait tomber la
structure en métal de 3 mètres 50 et
l'ont embarqué sur une brouette
on ignore leur motivation tout comme on
ignore d'où provient cette étrange
monolithes
mais on sait désormais comment il a
disparu
[Musique]
il tente de la ville de green town sont
très inquiet suite à la disparition
d'une sculpture qui dominait la ville
regardez voilà un phallus géant de 2
mètres de haut en bois
la police allemande enquête job on va
aller du côté de bruxelles avec un
eurodéputé hongrois qui a participé à
une partouze il n'y a pas d'autre il n'y
a pas d'autres mots il y avait une
partie fine avec des diplomates avec des
déploiements plus normatif in non la
prise à une copie de partouzes oui une
ambitieuse et conduite par moussa et
rien de plus joli en fait orgie une
orgie fine partie de plaisir non nous
jambes en l'air
vingt-cinq hommes dénudés ont été
découvert à l'étagé d'un bar parmi eux
plusieurs diplomates et un homme que
vous voyez à l'image qui cite ont fui
pour ne pas être arrêté il a été
retrouvé le 20 août il sanglante et
voilà c'est joseph 7 gère un eurodéputé
hongrois qui est connu notamment pour
ses positions homophobes un bon et pour
couronner le tout il avait sur lui une
pilule d'ecstasy ne s'agit pas d'un gang
bang dans les hôpitaux ils m'ont donné
des précisions tout à l'heure
leye tech dans tire dans tous les cas ce
dont tu as choisi
bien sûr et j'ai une question tu sais
comment on dit coffre-fort en belgique
voilà je t'ai fait peur ces coffres de
vous en avez ras la casquette vous est
au bout du rouleau vous avez envie
d'hurler et bien ce numéro est fait pour
vous vous appelez vous criez un bon coup
et vous raccrochez la créatrice explique
évidemment il n'y a personne au bout du
fil c'est un répondeur
d'ailleurs les messages sont enregistrés
et publiée sur internet de manière
anonyme y en a déjà des milliers
disponibles je vous ai sélectionné
quelques messages mise en ligne cette
nuit ça fait un bond de se défouler de
manière à devenir soyons précis de
séjour sera personnes regardez les
autres réponses à bas le hamas qui est
dit sarkozy
nathalie vous reconnaissez nicolas
sarkozy là d'accord nathalie je crois
que vous avez deux présidents de retard
c'est emmanuel macron mai
hier se tenait le grenelle de
l'éducation un colloque sur le thème
quelques professeurs ou 21e siècle au
menu des tables rondes dont certaines
commises obligeant visioconférence des
visions parfaitement huilé mais comment
c'était à répondre à cette question à
béatrice gilles nous entendent pas c'est
de quelle origine rudy les flamands vous
êtes médecin
non non du tout je sais pas quand vous
appelez renvoie le scalpel musique était
peut-être écouté c'est une grande
première c'est pas la meilleure yade
aura des meilleurs dans les années qui
viennent mais au moins ça lance le
mouvement
ils nous entendent pas assez on le voit
ici que s'est désactivé le temps qu'un
leurre micro et désactiver le nôtre
désactivé béatrice coûteux et moi dans
ces conditions je l'adaptation du film
du fils mullan puis ce sera l'arrivée
nouveaux pics arrête de rigoler c'est
bête articule pas encore donc on vient
d'avoir dix bata 6 kw
c'est pourquoi je te mets une très pâle
7 8 9 10 10
la difficulté de mon plein c'est la
cuisson des rouges et parce que vraiment
c'est sûr que le chef va m'attendre au
quart de tour sur ça on veut laisser
caroline veille casser un oeuf par
exemple pour voir
oui mais j'ai mis mon pantalon dès
dimanche on essaye eksi allez courage
[Rires]
[Musique]
c
paru en ethiopie
c'est un serveur cosmique
hyper bonne état d'esprit parce que je
vais trop bien servir que 5 est en effet
tombé par terre ça aussi je leur dis pas
le manger
je préfère ça après avec le recul je me
dis quand même c'est un peu chargé on
est un peu partout on a du sel dans
notre assiette
et puis l'odeur samson à marée basse et
une de vos culottes je sais pas sa santé
la moule pas frêche ont fait la petite
au petit coin
je lui commission oui au bal à papa
s'attarde
heureusement que c'est celle-là on
remercie les rédacteurs c'est la
fontaine par le plongeon au moins
personne se sert pour moi ça ça va
dedans ça va car monde hors du tunnel
chaud à l'intérieur tu sors le fils tu
branches ça même ça il disait qu'il
faudrait fallait pas hésiter à les
pincer pour la pression au cas où oms
aranza salut rentrer dans le troufion et
ça ressemble à un réseau wi fi sync
dessus office
[Musique]
je t'en veux pas c'est pas ta fausse
faut des mamans et vous sylvie vous êtes
dans une usine de chocolat et bruno
ceyssat cela vous fait des chocolats aux
pruneaux je fourre les prudents et je
prépare une lettre près on est passé à
deux doigts de la censure maintenant que
je paie ce dans le bain c'est pas pour
me la péter mais j'ai pu le temps quoi
la ld 19h56 je vais aller manger et
prendre ma douche faut laisser la star
tranquille et merde pour la suite